schon vor 70 jahren wurde dieser
mysteriöse zustand der materie in der
theorie vorhergesagt doch erst jetzt ist
einem deutschen forschungsteam der
eindeutige beweis gelungen die fachleute
aus stuttgart konnten tatsächlich die
existenz eine super festkörpers
nachweisen bei dem das material achtung
super flüssig und fest zugleich ist mord
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
diese sache widerspricht total unseren
vorstellungen von aggregatzuständen die
man aus dem alltag kennt im klartext
gemeint sind natürlich fest flüssig und
gasförmig und der physik kennt man aber
noch weitere materiezustände
beispielsweise plasma oder supra fluide
einem forschungsteam aus stuttgart ist
jetzt das gelungen worauf expertin
experten weltweit seit jahren
hinarbeiten die rede ist von dem
nachweis eines weiteren sehr exotischen
materie zustandes konkret geht es um den
sogenannten super festkörper hierbei ist
das material flüssig und fest zugleich
dafür sorgen effekte aus der
quantenphysik der super fluide zustand
des materials überlagert sich hier mit
dem festen oder anders gesagt einzelne
atome sind entweder teil der super
flüssigkeit oder aber teil des kristalls
und das völlig unvorhersehbar kurz zum
verständnis super fluide sind
flüssigkeiten oder gase die keine innere
reibung aufweisen sie verfügen über
keine entropie und zudem über eine
unendlich hohe wärmeleitfähigkeit
innerhalb eines solchen stoffes kann
also kein temperaturunterschied erzeugt
werden solche super fluide kommen im
kern von neutronensternen vor oder aber
auch in ultrakalten helium in ihrem
experiment arbeitete das stuttgarter
forschungsteam mit dispo sie um atom die
bis zum absoluten nullpunkt bei minus
273 grad celsius heruntergekühlt wurden
die atome wechsel wirkten dann auf zwei
verschiedene arten und weisen zum einen
stoßen sie zusammen wenn sich zwei atome
sehr nahe kommt doch auch über eine
längere distanz können sich diese atome
anziehen oder abstoßen das liegt an den
magnetischen wechselwirkungen über die
sie verfügen das nutzte das physik team
aus und terry
die magnetische dipol wechselwirkung so
aus dass diese nicht nur eine super
affinität ausbildeten sondern zeitgleich
auch eine kristalline gitterstruktur so
entstand ein super fest körper dazu die
beiden physiker
min ianu und fabian bröcker die an der
studie beteiligt waren
die periodische kristallbildung konnten
wir direkt optisch feststellen und die
quantenmechanische überlagerung durch
interferenz experimente testen
der endgültige beweis für diesen erfolg
gelang mit hilfe von schallwellen die
fachleute ließen diese mit zwei
verschiedenen geschwindigkeiten durch
den erschaffenen super festkörper laufen
da der super festkörper ja zeitgleich
fest und flüssig ist konnte eine
charakteristische zweite form von
schallwellen beobachtet werden diese
wies eine sehr geringe geschwindigkeit
auf eine premiere und der endgültige
beweis dafür dass es sich bei der
erzeugten materie tatsächlich um einen
super festkörper handelt eine echte
premiere denn obwohl dieser exotische
zustand bereits in den 50er jahren
vorhergesagt wurde konnte er bislang
nicht zweifelsfrei und eindeutig
nachgewiesen werden und so hatte sich in
den vergangenen jahren ein echter
wettstreit zwischen forschungsteams
weltweit entwickelt die stuttgarter
fachleute feiern ergebnis dazu der
wissenschaftler tilman pfau in diesem
weltweiten wettrennen ist es uns damit
zum ersten mal gelungen alle drei
bedingungen für einen super soliden
zustand in einem experiment mit
ultrakalten dispo sie um atomen zu
demonstrieren superschwere elemente die
jagd nach neuer materie anklicken
anschauen und doktor watson abonnieren
also hier klicken
einer meiner absoluten lieblings kanäle
bis dann bleibt dran